cain un sujet qui jeu ça va beaucoup
faire réagir non seulement sur un
plateau mais vous qui nous regardent et
puisque dans les grandes gueules sur rmc
story on a découvert le témoignage
poignant de laura laura ces sept jeunes
femmes victimes de violences conjugales
qui vit aujourd'hui avec la peur au
ventre depuis la remise en liberté de
son ex conjointe on comptera trois à
quatre heures du matin ivre mort il me
sauter dessus m'étranglait et me taper
pouvait laver dans la chambre de ma
fille chaque fois fallait que j'y aille
pour faire pompon il faut il a fait
tomber par terre
il n'y a pas de justice fait jean paul
huchon peu plus cheminée ça va jamais
s'arrêter
l'homme était mise en examen placé en
détention provisoire pour tentative
d'homicide mail été remis en liberté
conditionnelle
il a aujourd'hui interdiction
d'approcher laura et sa fille en dehors
quand même de visites médiatisées serre
que le rat doit quand même sous contrôle
présenter sa fille à cet homme qui a
voulu le tuer c'est ça la justice
française qui ne protège pas visiblement
la victime mais qui accorde des droits à
celui qui s'est rendu coupable d'une
tentative d'homicide
alors une situation qui est assez
ubuesque je rappelle quelques chiffres
des violences conjugales en 2019 50
femmes tuées par leur compagnon ou
ex-compagnon en 2019 nous sommes qu'au
mois de mai 1 50 femmes tuées soit une
victime tous les deux jours et demi 130
femmes et 25 enfants tués en 2018 dans
le cadre de ces mêmes violences
conjugales cent cinquante et une
tentative d'homicide au sein du groupe
il faut rappeler également qu'un homme
meurt tous les treize jours de violences
conjugales c'est un vrai fléau
là on parle d'un cas particulier mais on
va évidemment élargir en tout cas sur
sur ces cas là de ces femmes qui se
retrouvent j'allais dire confrontés à
leur ex conjoint ex agresseurs peut-être
agresseurs à nouveau et de cette peur au
ventre qu'elles ont qu'est ce qu'on en
pense jimmy mohamed bâ écoutez c'est
vrai que du matin au soir on nous
bassine avec des leçons de féminisme
mémoire que je trouve du féminisme au
rabais on nous dit les règles c'est
tabou il faut en parler nous parle d une
écriture inclusive et on se rend compte
que l'on passe à côté
alors peut-être que l'on peut pas dire
qu'il faut hiérarchiser les souffrances
mais si la chemise les femmes battues et
qui meurt sous les coups de leur
compagnon
j'aimerais qu'à la fin du quinquennat
d'un mandat et bien ce chiffre diminue
peut-être que bon on va dire qu'il
n'existe plus ou moins que ça diminue et
que les gens qu'ils soient condamnés
soient condamnés très sévèrement parce
qu'on a l'impression qu'on va en prison
plus facilement pour un peu de drogue
alors que quand on tape sa femme mais
finalement ça passe même chose lorsqu'on
parle du bracelet électronique qui
pourrait éloigner un petit peu les
prédateurs que sont les marais qui dans
cette histoire à mon sens le mari perd
tous ses droits le droit d'être papa le
droit marla on rappelle que ce monsieur
a tenté de la tuer sous les yeux de son
enfant qu'il était en prison préventive
et qu'il en est ressorti dans la tente
du procès et que dans le cadre de cette
attente du procès c'est la raison pour
laquelle on l'autorisent
évidemment avec une tierce personne à
voir à ce que la femme présente l'enfant
au papa avec la présence de cette
fameuse personnes et il a une injonction
en dehors de ce cadre là il n'a pas le
droit de l'approcher lit de l'enfant et
de la femme mais il n'a pas de bracelet
les talents qui pourraient c'est une loi
qui a été votée en 2017 et marlène
schiappa a été interrogé à ce sujet a
dit oui son expérimentation va avoir non
attends quoi un bracelet électronique ça
peut faire très facilement
et puis ça peut tranquilliser les femmes
qu'est ce que vous en pensez d'amiens je
pense que jimmy a raison sur le fait
qu'il existe deux féminisme un féminisme
au rabé un petit peu voilà pas forcément
nécessaire et un autre qui était
vraiment évoluer la condition de la
femme
je pense que nous devons vraiment tous
écouté cet appel à l'aide de cette femme
qui est tourmenté et qui finalement subi
une double peine
d'un côté elle doit se remettre du
traumatisme lié à la tentative de
meurtre de son mari et d'un autre côté
elle doit être confronté à ce mari par
une décision de justice donc je trouve
qu'on doit vraiment s'occuper de son cas
néanmois je pense que le père s'il n'a
pas été condamné s'il leur présent il en
est en danger cette affaire ne sais pas
s'il n'a pas été condamné il est présumé
innocent pour l'instant s'il n'a pas été
condamné et s'il ne représente aucun
danger pour l'enfant je pense qu'il a
tous les droits de voirie et c'est bien
normal
après le reste je ne savais pas que le
fait d'avoir fait une tentative
d'homicide de vos sous les yeux de
l'enfant s'est tu sais déjà une
maltraitance
si la présence mais pour l'instant c'est
entre les mains de la justice
et si la fille on sait pas aussi moi
j'aimerais bien entendre le point de vue
de la fille ce qu'elle a envie de voir
son père aussi parce que c'est peut-être
aussi à cet âge là un manque de ne pas
voir son père donc moi je remercie la
place de cette personne donc vous vous
dites attention il ya les droits de
l'après du du présumé coupable et mais
j'ai l'impression qu'un peu vous oubliez
balle
la réelle victimes parce qu'on
représente pas mais il ya une réelle ans
après vous l'avez rappelé c'est à dire
que la personne ne peut pas être
confronté à son mari sans une tierce
personne donc on peut imaginer aussi
qu'il ya une petite sécurité même si je
joue la corde ça n'empêche que si cette
personne est complètement les droits du
père ce sont les droits du père et quoi
qu'il advienne il c'est normal que elles
doivent présenter l'enfant qu'il n'est
pas condamné et tant qu'ils ne
représentent aucun danger et que
finalement on lui à parrot se retire à
l'autorité par anglet principe de
précaution peut-être non parce qu elle l
explique dans le sujet qu'il venait
notamment dans la chambre qu'elle
faisait barrage dans la chambre de l'efs
de la petite parce que il y allait
visible et il a même des violences et
parce qu'elle s'interpose et entrepôt
pour justement éviter qu'il ne dispute
entre le papa et la maman mais en
l'occurrence finalement assez d'enfants
et c'est la maman que c'est le papa qui
est dans la chambre de l'enfant et la
maman s'interposait et pas il faisait
barrage de son corps pour éviter qu'il y
ait des soucis avec l'enfant voyez ce
que je veux dire ouais je pense que
c'est un cas extrêmement complexe et de
toute façon il existe malheureusement il
était ivre il a tenté de l'assassiner
tu dis que c'est elle représente
vraiment une en escalade mais s'il
représente un danger pour la mère et
l'enfant
mais il a frappé sa femme il peut
frapper l'enfant s'il est ivre avec la
famille peut faire exactement une chose
avec l'enfant peut-être aussi notre abus
on n'en sait rien alors là oui je mets
innocent sur rien dire sur les plateaux
présumé innocent là je suis désolé j'ai
trés aucune complaisance envers lui et à
mon sens il a perdu tous ses droits de
père de marie il ne peut plus voir son
enfant tout ça parce que visiblement le
l'argument de damien et un père reste un
père sa femme
on était ivre on peut taper son enfant
game over c'est fini fameuse est
d'accord émilie roy ya deux choses que
je voudrais opposé à l'argumentation de
damien c'est que pour moi les violences
conjugales s'est pas seulement des coûts
c'est aussi une violence psychologique
qui est très très dur à vivre pour la
mer et aussi pour l'enfant il ya un
enfant qui voit évidemment là il ya
quatre millions d'enfants aujourd'hui
qu'ils sont qui sont témoins de ça et on
en garde des séquelles je vous parle en
connaissance de cause hautmont en
gardent des séquelles à vie
on se souvient avis est pire que ça il
ya certains enfants qui vont reproduire
le schéma plus tard que cette violence
qu'ils ont vu des tout petits jeux
vraiment je te le dis un enfant qui a vu
son père frappé sa mère ou sa mère
frappé son père n'a plus envie de voir
le parent violent clairement très
clairement et je suis d'accord avec
jimmy il ya plus de droits dans ce cas
là tu es juste quelqu'un de violent
soit tu te soignes mais vraiment
tu fais de la prison où tu te sois tu
vas voir un psy et après potentiellement
on voit si tu peux revoir ton enfant
sinon plus de droits mais de divine
évidemment et comme d'habitude damien
n'a rien compris à l'histoire il a déjà
été violent avec ses filles il l'a fait
tomber et elle le dit dans dans son
témoignage et dans le reportage
je suis totalement d'accord avec jimmy
ce monsieur je ne comprends pas cette
justice française qui dans ces cas là
est juste à vomir parce qu'on veut
absolument défendre le point de vue du
père et respecter ses droits
mais à côté de ça les victimes sont
laissés pour compte j'ai injustement
rend un petit peu actualiser vos
chiffres de tout à l'heure valérie il ya
quatre jours il ya une femme de 56 ans
encore qui est morte assassinée par son
mari et elle était la 54e depuis le 1er
janvier
rappelez mesdames que vous n'êtes pas
seuls et je vous pouvez numériser le 39
c'est la ligne et notamment à la main de
violence femmes info mais c'est juste
c'est juste inacceptable que la justice
laisse les victimes pour compte et que
malheureusement après il y en a qui
meurt alors qu'elles ont déjà tiré la
sonnette d'alarmé et donc dans cette
affaire il faut souligner qu' elle a été
sauvée parce que des voisins sont inter
sont intervenus ont appelé et c'est vrai
que parfois on opposer on dit il ya un
silence assourdissant du voisinage etc
dans cette affaire là elle elle doit son
salut au fait que des voisins ont réagi
et donc n'hésitez pas il vaut mieux
parfois signalé à tort oui et puis s'en
excuser parce que l'on peut parfois
avoir les disputes un peu haute en
couleurs en tout cas n'ayez s'il ya le
moindre doute sauvé ces femmes il faut
peut-être faire évoluer la loi quand on
est légitime défense
rapidement très vite j'ai un ami qui
radiologue qui a vu une femme ce qui
s'est fait battre par son mari elle
avait les mains cassé et le visage
tuméfié
cette femme fait du karaté et donc elle
s'est défendue le monsieur il fait un
mètre 90 100 kg et forcément va lui a
mis un coup et bien la femme a été mis
en garde à vue parce que comme l'a fait
du karaté c'est considéré par une arme
ces points comme une armada citations
dont kout est la loi peut être pour les
femmes je ne sais pas d'accord on est
d'accord
dites nous ce que vous en pensez avec le
hashtag sécu dlt on vous mettra bien
évidemment sur notre nos réseaux sociaux
les numéros d'appel d'urgence et je ne
peux que rejoindre également tous ceux
qui seraient témoins de ces de ces
violences a alerté la police
l'entourage etc